next on public lives Pulitzer
prize-winning historian David Herbert
Donald explores the friendships of
Abraham Lincoln in his latest we are
Lincoln men it lasts an hour David
Herbert Donald is clearly the world's
leading expert on Abraham Lincoln the
man and the president though his famous
book Lincoln is universally considered
the definitive biography of the
president professor donald uses his new
book we are lincoln men to reveal
another often overlooked side of this
legend professor donald explores the
life of one of the most private and
mysterious presidents through the eyes
of his closest friends and offers
valuable insights into how his
relationships affected his presidency
professor Donald's book Lincoln when the
prestigious Lincoln Prize and was a
best-seller he has twice won the
Pulitzer Prize for a biography in 1961
for Charles Sumner and the coming of the
Civil War and in 1988 for look homeward
a life of Thomas Wolfe he is the Charles
Warren professor emeritus of American
history and American civilization at
Harvard University please welcome to
Chicago David Herbert Donald
oh thank you very much it relieves the
joy to be back in Chicago it's a
wonderful city such an exciting city and
I've always loved it I'd hoped to come
back more and more frequently I thought
I'd talk tonight a little about this new
book of mine called we are lincoln men
and perhaps i ought to begin by
explaining the title he comes from a
letter that John Hay won over Lincoln's
private secretaries wrote to his other
secretary John Jean Nicolet in the 1880s
when they were preparing there they
thought definitive ten-volume
Magisterial biography of Lincoln using
the Lincoln papers for the first time
they were both audit Republicans but
they didn't want to make you sound like
a campaign document in ten volumes so he
wrote to nickel a we want to seem
absolutely impartial in our presentation
we want readers to think of us as two
seraphim's on clouds above twanging
their harps impartially as they recount
the history of the war and then hey said
but there's one reservation about this
we do remember all the way through that
we are lincoln men this is a book about
people who thought of themselves as
lincoln men they were close friends they
thought of lincoln and their
relationship to lincoln i think tell
something about them it tells even more
about the President and I hope you tell
something about the importance of
friendship in history now shortly after
Lincoln's assassination people
biographers historians began asking
questions naturally enough of how did
this man who came from such an
undistinguished background who had
hardscrabble beginnings who had little
education who had no wealth he had no
family behind him how did such a man
rise to power to success and how did he
come to be so completely capable as
president when they asked these
questions about those who had known
Lincoln back in his Illinois days they
got almost always the same kinds of
answers they were told again and again
that Lincoln rose because of his
capacity to make and to hold friends for
instance just take one little episode
during his brief service in the Black
Hawk War in the 1830s he so endeared
himself to his men in his company that
30 years later they remembered Lincoln
was our Idol one soldier said there was
not a man but was obedient to every word
he spoke and would fight to the death
for Lincoln all the men in the company
he was there another as well as the
regiment to which he and they belong
claimed that they almost worshipped our
Lincoln in every phase of his life he
attracted such devoted kinds of
followers so that one old-timer out in
New Salem when asked the secret of
Lincoln's success gave us the sink five
word exploration
he said Lincoln had nothing but friends
but the same people began asking other
people who knew Lincoln perhaps even
better and more intimately over a longer
period of time and they rejected that
explanation John Todd Stewart Lincoln's
first law odd thought that Lincoln was
incapable of friendship Lincoln did
forget his friends Stewart said there
was no part of his nature which drew him
into acts of gratitude for his friends
he was by some considered cold-hearted I
was indifferent toward his friends agree
to nothing on our politician who worked
with him for 30 years he was the warm
friend of a few men said governor
Oglesby Illinois he added a bit lamely
but he was the friend of mankind David
Davis the judge who was responsible more
than any other man for Lincoln's
domination in 1860 said Nathan had no
strong emotional feelings for any person
for mankind or thing and William Henry
Herndon Lincoln's law partner for 16
years
agreed with these appraisals like that
he said rose through his own exertion
he did not rise because he had friends
he was Herndon declared the most shut
mouth man who ever existed I love the
phrase shut mouth man
is that a wonderful phrase to describe a
politician who does not reveal his
secrets but hidden is my problem in my
paradox I would like to explore how a
man who had no intimate friends was also
a man who had nothing but friends and
that is the theme of was this new book
in working on it I think of it as an
exploration in not merely of Lincoln and
Illinois and of the Civil War period but
an exploration of friendship the meaning
of friendship and of his significance as
a shaping political and public behavior
to do this I found very difficult to
know exactly where to go for sources
naturally I went back to the records of
the time I went back to the interviews
that turned and collected to find out
what his so-called friends said about
Lincoln and got remarkably little out of
them
I turned next to the works of some
sociologists and educators who've done
important work in studying the
importance of friendship especially in
the early years and I learned even more
from conversations and correspondence
with some leading psychoanalysts who
explore the problems caused by the lack
of close friends but even these did not
satisfy me the work of these specialists
led me back to the history of philosophy
and I began reading it probably enough
for American historian what Montaigne
what Thomas Aquinas and what cicero had
to say about friendship and in turn all
of these ultimate led me back to
Aristotle Ariston made the basic and
still enduring typology the
classifications of friendship that
really all subsequent works have drawn
on and have echoed according to
Aristotle there are three kinds
friendships there are the pleasurable
friendships there are the useful
friendships and the perfect friendships
and Abraham Lincoln's life gives a very
good opportunity for examining all three
kinds of friendships now many of
Lincoln's associations associates fell
clearly into Aristotle's category of
pleasurable our friendships we could
simply enjoyed being with some men
I don't include women there because
Lincoln was never comfortable around
women early any women at all but among
some men he was very comfortable and he
just enjoyed me with him for example in
his early days out in New Salem he
enjoyed being with a rough rough necks
of the Clarys Grove area who would come
into town on the weekends and they would
drink a great deal and they would raise
hell generally he also enjoyed those
more than that erasing with them and of
course with his long legs he got out
racing anybody wrestling and he was
extremely good at that and other sports
like that there was very little there of
intellectual companionship but they
enjoyed being together
he enjoyed these relations and they did
to me and other years ahead they would
be some of his very strongest supporters
they would go around with him on
campaigns and go to elections in some
non keep order among disorderly crowds
so that their peer Lincoln could be
heard they loved him and they followed
him and they enjoyed him he enjoyed
these associations a great deal for
instance in the winter Black Hawk War
which I've already mentioned broke out
in 18 1830s the Indian chief Black Hawk
had come back into Illinois to reclaim
lands he claimed had been taken from him
by the government there was a war to
drive him out Lincoln and the other
young men were subjected to the call to
the militia and of course they all
served in those days when the militia
was called out they gathered in some
central place usually a pasture of green
and they then elected their own officers
somebody would dominate one somebody
dominate
another in the case of Lincoln's company
somebody nominated everybody expected to
be elected a wealthy mill owner named
Kirkpatrick and so he was nominated he
stood out in front and his followers
were supposed to stand behind him
somebody then nominated to his surprise
really lengthening he stood out here and
the men began moving over two-thirds of
them followed Lincoln only a handful
stood behind Coe Craig Patrick and then
personally they looked around they
didn't want to be alone so they drifted
over there to leaving that poor man over
there all by himself so like that was
himself elected this was something it
gave him enormous pleasure he remembered
it the rest of his life years later
after you'd served four terms in the
state legislature as he served as house
in the House of Representatives in
Washington after he twice been the
candidate of his party for United States
Senate he still remembered this on him
honor he declared that his election as
militia captain was a success which gave
me more pleasure than any I have had
since this was the nature of Lincoln's
enjoyable friendships throughout his
life that Lincoln also associated
himself with people who fell into
Aristotle's second category that of the
useful friendship and he never hesitated
about drawing on them for help very
early when elected to the state
legislature at the age of I believe is
23 he realized that he didn't have any
clothes to wear as he went to Vandalia
he said these are the rags that you went
around you sailor man he had to make a
respectable appearance he said so he
went out at to a wealthy property owner
near you Salem named Coleman's Smoot
and said to him I need $200 to make a
respectable showing in Vandalia will you
lend it to me smooth who was a useful
friend said of course I will without
hesitation he gave him the $200 there
was no note there was no interest
what could link that have put up in the
way of interest he had no money
whatsoever he knew that he would
ultimately be repaid like him by the way
took the $200 spent $60 of it on his
first suit of clothes now that doesn't
sound like a lot to us these days but
he's your lawful inflation
that would be at least $600 which was
quite a lot of money to pay some horse
suit for a man who had never had one
before such useful friends surrounded
Lincoln throughout his life and they
helped him there was one for example who
gave him free room and board while he
was studying to be a surveyor another
lady blow books so he could pass the bar
still another fear didn't told him of
while he went to Springfield to get his
practice of law started Herndon his
young law partner was his dog's body he
did everything for him he managed the
office kept up the books of the office
he looked up references in the State
Library he collected political
references for Lincoln's campaign
speeches now according to Aristotle
people do not shift from one category of
friendship or not if you are a useful
friend you are not an enjoyable friend
and you're not so on but this was not
true at Lincoln's case in Lincoln's case
many times the useful friend also
gradually became an enjoyable friends
such was his connection with William
Henry Seward his secretary of state you
all know this the wood had been a leader
in the Republican Party in the formation
of that party had hoped for the
nomination in 1860 had been bitterly
disappointed when Lincoln rather than he
was chosen or hid the Republican Party
and for a time they seemed that he was
going to salt could that be part of the
new administration Lincoln knew he
needed to co-opt soon he was a head of
of important faction of the Republican
Party so he offered him the premier post
in his administration that a Secretary
of State Seward hesitated but ultimately
decided well he would indeed take it he
thought he would be the premier of the
administration and he would run the
government while Lincoln would be
largely an inexperienced figurehead all
who simply are served in a nominal
capacity even before Lincoln was
inaugurated Seward made it clear that he
intended and wanted to dominate the
cabinet when he learned that his
Republican rival Salomon P chase was
going to be nominated to that cab
- he dashed off a hasty note - Lincoln
you can see that the note itself that it
was a hasty production he's just sort of
squiggled it off he's indecipherable
handwriting dear mr. president
circumstances have arisen that prevent
me from accepting the appointments I
previously mentioned I wish you well
wouldn't mean you saw it he was not
going to be have arrival in the cabinet
now Lincoln you very well that this was
a dangerous situation he needed Seward
in his cabinet he couldn't afford to
have him withdrawal on the other hand he
couldn't as he told Nikolai his
secretary private secretary I can't
afford the lights - and take the first
trick so what he did was to let out a
rumor a rumor that the president had
heard Seward was not happy with being
Secretary of State and Lincoln might
appoint him minister to Great Britain
and that if he did there would be a
vacancy in the State Department to which
Lincoln would undoubtedly appoint
someone else who was considered hostile
to New York state interests now counting
on Seward self-interest and on his
self-importance Lincoln thought he could
Bluff him in to saying well I guess I
really have to serve and he was
absolutely correct
also it brooded over it and then writing
to his wife that I'm afraid that I don't
dare to go home and I don't dare to go
to England and leave the country to
chance he accepted and he of course
joined the cabinet now the two men
initially worked on a rather distant
formal kind of relationship but
presently that formality that usefulness
became really much more enjoyable Seward
lived in a house that was diagonally
across Lafayette Park from the White
House mrs. Lee would often was not in
Washington mrs. Lincoln was often
otherwise occupied so in evenings very
frequently Lincoln would stroll across
Lafayette Park or to Seward's house he
would find him free and they would sit
in Seward's our study and so would will
recline his great easy chair was a
snifter of brandy and one of his
infernal black cigars
he spoke all over the place and Lincoln
would President of the United States put
his feet up on the fender of the
fireplace and they would tell stories
and they would swap any notes and news
and gossip and presently they got really
to like each other and this in turn grew
into a joking kind of friendship for
instance one morning early on in the
administration Seward coming over to the
White House to check on how things were
going found I love this the President of
the United States shining his shoes
there in the marble halls of the White
House
mr. president said their secretary in
Washington we do not black at our own
shoes Oh said Lincoln looking up well
mr. secretary whose shoes do you blacken
then another day when they were walking
down Pennsylvania Avenue and again this
gives something of the flavor of the
time he were in the middle of a civil
war Washington's threatened always
fighting the President of the United
States six foot four inches tall his
Secretary of State who was a little more
than five feet tall walked arm-in-arm
undistorted
unguarded down Pennsylvania Avenue
window-shopping and they look into the
windows what's being sold with what's
going on and above the street they see
Lincoln sees a new sign hanging out over
the street it says T are strong look
sister Lincoln who could never resist a
pun no matter how dreadful it was looks
he says Seward T are strong but coffee
are stronger and the president of the
Secretary of State enjoying whoops of
laughter in the middle of Pennsylvania
Avenue
one more honor of this maybe wouldn't be
out of order a little later on in the
war Lincoln in Seward variety in
Virginia to see the troops the roads
will be miserable run it and the driver
of the carriage was bursting out and
most profane language possible whipping
his poor horses to pull him along and
Lincoln wrapped on the ceiling of the
carriage privately he's dead
are you an Episcopalian driver
astonished look
no what's the president he said I ain't
much of anything but when I go to the
at all I get yes I go to the Methodist
Church Oh says Lincoln beside him
Oh says like that I thought you must be
an Episcopalian you swear just like over
the steward here and he's an Episcopal
Church warden it was that kind of go
back and forth relationship that they
both enjoyed it was useful and it was
also pleasurable now relaxing and
pleasurable as such friendships war none
of them ever reached Aristotle's third
category the perfect friendship between
men now that's Aristotle's phrasing
these days we would not use his sexist
terminology we'd say between women too
but Aristotle was talking about men such
a perfect friendship is not based on
interest is not based on hope for
advancement but simply on the love the
good men have for other good men and
they love each other because of their
goodness this was the friendship of
Damon and Pythias
this was the friendship of David and
Jonathan this was the perfect friendship
and perfect friendships are rare even
Aristotle who was surrounded by
disciples and sycophants I said supposed
to have said on his deathbed all my
friends there is no true friend and
certainly Lincoln had trouble finding a
true friend the explanation is not quite
clear there are probably several reasons
for it perhaps this was because any is
boyhood the Lincoln's lived in such an
isolated area in southern Indiana where
there were so few people there were
literally no other boys the Lincoln's
aged for him to play with Spencer County
in southern in Indiana an area of about
the size of Rhode Island had
approximately 200 families and we've
gone over the tax records very closely
and finally they were in that whole area
maybe somewhere in the neighborhood of
seven or nine boys who might have been
more or less of Abraham's age but they
were scattered is like being one part of
Rhode Island and other and the other
part of Rhode Island there was nobody
close enough to play with to see or to
enjoy to confide in
on a day-by-day basis perhaps a
Lincoln's failure to find a friend in
these days also had something to do with
the early death of his mother when he
was only about 10 years old that death
left Lincoln emotionally paralyzed since
the death of a parent does for a small
child and he was unable to build close
emotional ties to others close around
him
whatever the explanation Lincoln lacked
an essential childhood experience that
is of having a chum a pal a person of
his own age the sex in who could have
confide freely whose friendship was
something that would help him define
himself and give himself autonomy so I
called a psychoanalyst like Harry stack
Sullivan tell us the boy who's never had
a chum is likely to find it difficult in
later life to establish close emotional
ties to deGrasse a moment I've been
working on friendship for a long long
time and boring everybody about what my
talk about not too long ago before this
book was published I was having an
annual examination at a part of the
Great Boston hospitals and it one of the
major departments it was poking in
probing the way doctors do and I
supposed to relax me he was said tell me
what you're working on and I said I'm
working on my friendship and talked
about the importance of friendship of
having the Chum and how the boy who
doesn't have a Chum he's gonna be
emotionally deprived all of his life and
I looked up in this great man this great
a doctor who's respected all over the
world
I looked up and tears were running on
his faces I never heard a friend I feel
so sad I didn't know what to say and I
still don't know what I should have said
to this poor man but it is quite clear
that the other boy who does not have a
friend who does not have a Chum in youth
is very likely to be an isolate later on
and there are good studies suggesting
that they may also become Moody and
depressed the melancholy that surrounded
Abraham Lincoln throughout most of his
life may have stemmed from failing to
have such an intimate connection
in his youth Lincoln was nearly 30 years
old when he finally found the perfect
friend a real true friend
after working for many years in New
Salem as you all know as riverboat
manned store keeper as postmaster as
surveyor he decided that he was when he
had studied law he was going to take the
bar and going to practice and move to
Springfield New Salem was dying anyway
so borrowing a horse he couldn't afford
one of his own borrowing some saddlebags
he put on one side his few clothes to
the other side two or three law books
and John into Springfield he looked
around for a place to stay and there was
nothing that he could afford he wanted
to find lodgings and they were too
expensive so he poked into the general
store on the town square
there in Springfield it's only
everything and he thought he might buy
equipment there perhaps the poor bidding
he met a young man there named Joshua
fry speed who was one of the part owners
of the store and yes then what would it
cost if I bought mattress blanket a
couple of pillows a couple of sheets and
speed Johnny down the figures and
totaled him up and said that's going to
cost you $17.90 said I don't have
seventeen dollars I don't have that
amount of money yes for credit until
Christmas saying if my lawyer
inexperienced succeed I'll pay you off
then and then Eddy sorrowfully and if I
feel in this I don't think I could ever
pay you now speed who barely knew
Lincoln at all so high over C was to get
into dead and thought he had a way of
avoiding a problem oh he said I have a
solution here upstairs he said I have a
very large room with a double bed if you
want to share it with me you're welcome
I'll be glad to have you where's the
room said Lincoln oh it's upstairs since
speed they can picked up his saddlebags
trots upstairs you hear the rustling of
for a minute YouTube this is a thump as
he drops the saddlebags to the floor
within a minute he comes down to his
face beaming that marvelous smile they
went from area well he says speed I
moved and for the next four years the
two men shared a room and a big this
well it a bit on many levels it was
unlikely friendship I must say
Lincoln was tall he was Gaulke he had
awkward manners that betrayed his
hardscrabble beginnings speed much
shorter four years younger had the
elegance and self possession that came
from being the son of a great Kentucky
planner who owned 70 odd slaves who
lived in grand style in Kentucky speed
had been educated in the best best
private academies and has had attended
college in Kentucky Lincoln as he
himself said had an aggregate of
education of less than one year but they
were remarkably compatible nevertheless
perhaps this is because they were both
from Kentucky perhaps because they were
both deeply interested in politics both
being Whigs opposed to the Jacksonians
perhaps it was because they both love
poetry Lincoln could recite great glass
of Shakespeare and many of the poems of
Robert Burns while speed before prefer
those of Lord Byron speed was mostly a
quiet listener though he had a good
sense of humor but Lincoln was in this
source of antidotes and to tall tales
indeed reputation gradually grew so that
after the store hours were over the
young men of Springfield began to gather
at Lincoln and speeds around the big
pot-bellied stove at night to hear more
tales and they would tell each other
stories they would recite poems and they
would debate informally and talk about
public issues but the strongest tie
between speed and Lincoln was none of
these it was their desire to get married
much admired in the best Springfield are
circles a speed was in love with a
beautiful pious but unapproachable
Matilda Edwards that are a very wealthy
Illinois resident who perhaps had doubts
about his purity of character Lincoln on
the other hand who just ditched married
Owens and unsuitable you know
woman out in New Salem I was directly
his attentions toward Mary Todd
a Kentucky belle who was visiting her
relatives in Springfield and so they
both were engaged in courtship at the
same time for nearly two years they
endorsed in the most protracted and
often animated discussions of their
potential marital affairs in what you
could think of as the first phase of
this discussion Lincoln by this point
has become engaged to Mary Todd and then
once he does so he has doubts Oh am I
ready to get married can I support a why
is this the wife for me and yes Pete how
could I break this engagement off and
speed gives him advice he tells him not
to do it basically at this point in
speed goes back to Kentucky and finds
his sweetheart there a lady named penny
innings and he becomes engaged to her
and he too has doubts and now he writes
to Lincoln saying uh I I'm engaged but I
have my doubts I'm not sure that either
sexually emotionally I can satisfy this
young woman maybe I shouldn't get
married at all and Lincoln advises you
know you go ahead and get married third
phase speed is married by this time and
Lincoln writes him one of those peculiar
letters in the whole Lincoln repertoire
since this is embarrassing letter to
write it's just a more personal than
anything that I've ever said if you were
not such a close friend I wouldn't dare
ask it but I simply have to ask you how
is your marriage working out I'm back
with Mary Todd and I'm not sure how it's
going to work but if your marriage isn't
working I'm not sure I should proceed
further he reassured him and so Lee got
married and speed got married and that
was the end of that it's if the story
didn't deal with such serious matters
you would think of it as kind of French
farce in three acts recent writer has
dealt better with it by saying that
Lincoln is speed while playing a role of
doctor and patient and phase one it is
they could who's the patient speed gives
the advice phase two species in trouble
Lincoln doctors him phase three
Lincoln's again in trouble speed tells
him what what to do and that's the way
they played it out then after the two
men were married
speed that move permanently back to
Kentucky it was hard to keep up such a
close friendship and over the years the
paths diverged they differed on issues
like slavery where speed resisted any
attempt to curb slavery and Lincoln
became increasingly anti-slavery but
even these differences did not make for
a break even a coldness and when Lincoln
was elected speed wrote to congratulate
him saying I know you you know that I
did not support you for president but I
think the country has made a wise choice
they can hope to have this old close
friend go with him to Washington and in
the months while he was president elect
he invited the speeds to come to Chicago
to meet with him to talk about the
future they did do so clearly had in
mind
offering speed some kind of post in the
new administration but speed made it
clear that he would not leave Kentucky
that his wife didn't want to leave
Kentucky that he was in a very
profitable business there in Kentucky
and did not want a government job so he
would stay in the end his decision may
have been fortunate for the country
because the Union and Lincoln needed a
spokesman to help hold Kentucky in the
Union and speed's role was a very
important one and during the months
ahead speed but from time to time go to
Washington and visit Lincoln and talk
with him
but of course he didn't see him
frequently and the old intimacy was gone
the result was that Lincoln as president
came to Washington with no close friends
with no intimate whatsoever he was all
by himself no I think it would be
reasonable for you to ask at this point
saying well what do these and the other
stories that I tell in we are Lincoln
man what do these have to say about any
larger kinds of questions oh do they
tell us anything about Lincoln's
presidency do they tell us anything
about how the conduct of the war was
carried on do they suggest that Lincoln
could have had better policies if he'd
had close intimate friends and the
answers to such questions necessarily
have to be
speculative because we don't know what
didn't happen but let me pose for you
some counterfactual historical scenarios
things that didn't happen but might have
happened suppose during the secession
crisis the southern states are pulling
out of the Union South Carolina parish
Mississippi's second and so on
supposedly could have had some close
confidential advisors with a broad
southern acquaintance which Lincoln
himself did not have Lincoln operated
throughout the first two years of the
war under the misapprehension that
secession was a minority movement only a
small mover of conspirators in the South
that most white Southerners were loyal
unionists who in the next election would
put these conspirators down this
obviously was a great misconception but
he had no one to tell him so he had no
one who traveled in the south to say
look this is a very dangerous situation
to say these things must be done if you
want to conciliate and win the unionists
in the south there was no one to perform
that function it seems possible as
possible I guess it was better
understanding and broader communications
won the Union cause in Virginia might
have triumphed and Lincoln might have
been able to hold that state in the
Union and you could imagine how
different the Civil War would have been
had Virginia remain loyal to the Union
but Lincoln had no adviser to tell him
how to do that well of course that
didn't happen let's take a second
scenario that didn't happen
oddly enough Lincoln did not like to
debate or argue for a lawyer
you would think that'd be his business
but he didn't it was easy pattern always
out in Springfield and later just like
to hear others argue a case back and
forth and he were here the pros and he
we hear the cons and then he would make
up his own mind he's not in Washington
and he has no friends gathered around
speeds are stove he has no kitchen
cabinet like Andrew Jackson he has
nobody to say look these are the pros
and these are the cons so he took to
developing him himself he developed a
habit
setting up for himself these are the
arguments in favor of such a position
and these are their arguments against
this position and having put them that
way oh he would test them often he would
test them by trying them out on anybody
who would listen take the case of
emancipation which became increasingly
important in the summer of 1862 Lincoln
of course was anti-slavery
he would like to freed the slaves but he
was under great pressure not to trouble
the South peculiar institution at a time
that the Union was not winning the war
in the summer of 1862 though the
pressures for emancipation grew so great
that he took two of his cabinet officers
out for a carriage ride and said to them
look the pressures are so great that I
think I'm going to have to issue a
proclamation of emancipation and this
news leaked out and people began to say
oh that's where the president is going
he got back to the White House an old
friend from Illinois was visiting he
almost the same day and he told that
friend well you know there precious for
emancipation but there great
difficulties about it and I'm not going
to issue Emancipation Proclamation if I
did fifty thousand soldiers would desert
in Kentucky in Tennessee you lay down
their arms and join the Confederates so
I won't do it
and that got out clearly people got
confused signals they thought Lincoln
was Vaseline are there you didn't know
his own mind he did but he needed to
test things out by expressing them
verbally if he had even one or two very
close friends only oh we could try these
ideas first before expressing them
publicly surely it would be less
misconception about his policies that
would have been easier to understand
just the way he was going what he was
doing let me try a third counterfactual
scenario one that didn't happen during
the Republican convention of 1864 in
Bulge of all which we nominated Lincoln
for the presidency Lincoln did nothing
whatsoever to express his opinion about
who should be the vice presidential
choice Hannibal Hamlin of being his
first vice president
a perfectly respectable not
distinguished vice president what price
president it was distinguished oh he was
okay oh he might have served in another
term and he wanted one but Lincoln did
not lift a finger for him he did not
intervene in behalf of anybody else he
let the delegates make their own choice
and for various reasons they finally
wound up choosing Andrew Johnson of
Tennessee they could not have made a
worse choice Andrew Johnson whatever you
say about his honesty his integrity his
bravery his standing holding his state
staying in the Union when his state left
in secession he was stubborn
he was vindictive he was partisan and he
was bigoted a close friend could have
told Lincoln look you don't want that
kind of man
in the White House a close friend would
have examine Andrew Johnson's Senate
record to say this is the record that he
has a vindictive inviting in the Senate
they would have examined his record as
military governor of Tennessee just say
he was hostile he was bitter
he was partisan you don't want that kind
of man and with such advice possibly
Lincoln could have found someone else
and some of the horrors of
reconstruction might have been avoided
but of course it didn't happen none of
my scenarios did indeed happen I find it
kind of fun to play with these
counterfactual scenarios to think of the
things that didn't happen that might
have happened I think but all of them
perhaps have a questionable first
premise that is that Lincoln with his
distrust of intimacy his unwillingness
to confide in anybody even intimates
could ever have been brought to accept
the views of his ego of a close friend
certainly no close friend however dear
to em could have budged him on certain
fundamentals he was supposed he was
inflexibly opposed to any extension of
slavery in the National territories no
yield there he knew was an absolute
finality that he would never agree to
the dissolution of the Union so nobody
could have counseled about that
and finally once he issued the
Emancipation Proclamation he
not a backtrack Tony he made that
abundantly clear
but with trusted experienced friends
perhaps the president might have dealt
with these issues rather differently or
in a more conciliatory fashion not to
say that he could have avoided the civil
war but at least he might have muffled
some of the battering criticism that
beleaguered Lincoln and his
administration during the war and surely
if Lincoln had been surrounded by
friends in the White House by trusted
friends he would have lived a happier
less isolated a less anguish life Milton
Eisenhower needs this wrote about the
president's need for a close personal
friend in the White House he knew this
at first and because of his close
relationship to his brother
President Eisenhower Milton eyes to have
a road most persons in leadership
Authority like to think out loud with
someone he deems to be intelligent
well-informed conscious of all the
nuances from fiscal policy to political
possibility can be trusted absolutely
never to divulge a secret and whom he
admires it's that kind of person who
should be the president's principal
confidant and Milton Eisenhower was
Eisenhower's confidant
some of our greatest presidents have had
such confidence to think in the 20th
century there is Woodrow Wilson and
Colonel Hobbes or there is Franklin
Roosevelt and Harry Hopkins of this John
F Kennedy and his brother Robert some of
our less successful presidents in the
20th century have been those who did not
have close friends who did not have
trusted confidants Nixon trusted nobody
as you all know once Bert Lance left
Washington Jimmy Carter had no one of
his own age and experience in whom he
could confide and Lincoln had no one
either as a result though he was
constantly surrounded by people though
he was always talking to people though
people were always demanding things from
him he was
throughout the war the loneliest man in
Washington thank you very much
take questions if you in value what to
the idea is to come down to the
microphones in front on the side if you
would please yes could you speak to the
president's relationship with the
stepbrother and why they weren't closer
and what became of him eventually right
background are there as you know link
his brother died when he was not quite
in Thomas link will be back to Kentucky
bought a new bride Sarah Bush Johnston a
widow with three children two girls and
a boy of about Lincoln's age back to
Indiana and Sarah Bush Johnson Lincoln
treated the Lincoln children absolutely
equal with her own she loved them she
took care of me she fed them she clothed
them and they were in terrible shape
when she got back there you would think
that with a boy approximately he's
enraged that the Johnston boy and
Lincoln or have grown up as as friends
they did we don't quite know why they
pop parties simply temperamental I
suspect the Johnston boy was rather dull
slow-witted and not very active until
Lincoln of course was the reverse of
this it's also the case that Thomas
Lincoln apparently favored his stepson
the Johnston boy / Lincoln whom he
somehow beat and he certainly worked
very very hard they just didn't get
along well and at times said one of the
relatives Lincoln and the boy or enemies
so they never grew up together as
friends though they might have in this
deprive him of the one possible source
here of an intimate friend in his early
years and that of course is a great pity
I think someone's coming down and out
I was wondering if you knew what
Lincoln's relationship or friendship
with cynic Simeon Francis was Simeon
Francis microphone expect discipline
Francis was an important man and in
Springfield was their close friendship
there not that I know there are great
many people who thought of themselves
and call themselves close friends of
Lincoln and the problem there is that we
don't really have any record to go on
for most of these and like it himself
referred to a great many people as
friends there's one very peculiar
reference about intimate friend named B
law or something is that who turned out
to be a confectioner who sold candy on
the square in Springfield who appears
nowhere else in the whole Lincoln record
so that that doesn't tell us it really
very much there were a lot of people who
knew a great deal about Lincoln who saw
him frequently one thing start Delia
Simeon Francis which is important but
also of branch of Stanton and of many
others we do not have any records from
these people saying Lincoln shared his
ideas would be about reconstruction or
about the fate of the Union about race
relations or any of these matters
there's simply no record that if there
was this type of intimacy we do have for
these five men that I have dealt with
here that kind of close relationship and
a record of it which is equally
important for the history yeah I've got
a question with two parts did Mary
Lincoln have the ability to make
friendships and would you consider her a
liability for Lincoln with his friends
right did we get that was Mary Lincoln a
liability to Lincoln because of her or a
relationship for her ability or
inability to make friends and I think
that's an interesting question first
I do think the baby Lincoln has been
badly treated by historians over the
years she's had a bum rap poor lady she
suffered a great deal and we think of
her in those tragic said later years
rather than in her early years what we
have to remember that first of all this
was a well-educated she was clever she
was witty she was articulate she was
outgoing and she had great difficulty in
accommodating herself to the style
first of all of Lincoln and of
Springfield if you were brought up in a
mansion in Kentucky with slaves to wait
on you to live in a little house in
Springfield not the house the Lincoln
House now which is double the size of
what Mary came to but a really small
house in Springfield where you child
after child four children in a row where
your husband is out of the circuit
sometime for six weeks at a time without
coming home well you cook over a hot
stove that you bring the wood Ian from
by yourself
from the backyard well you pump your own
water from your own pump this was hard
hard work and she had her difficulty
doing the one that I think that her temp
afraid from time to time that she was
often angry she did have friends in
Springfield and she helped Lincoln a
good deal in the early years politically
he said that she had better judgment of
character than he did of who was
reliable and who wasn't but as time went
on of course things changed considerably
and his merrie got to the white house
and got involved in the refurbishing the
White House with huge expenditures that
over and the budget she didn't know how
to make the budget come out right and
she tried to skimp and to save all of
these things
coupled with the tragic death of Willie
the most promising of the Lincoln our
children turned her into a very
different woman about 1862 so after that
I don't think mayor Lincoln was a much
of an asset to Lincoln and in turn he
did not confide in how much after he
became president because she'd been
notably indiscreet in leaking out
secrets
you refer to slavery as the I'm sorry a
little bit you refer to slavery as the
peculiar institution and it seems to me
that slavery's in throughout history is
the most typical institution and I just
wondered why it's called a peculiar
institution well thank you my old
professor at the University of North
Carolina Fletcher Greene said that the
person who finds the first time that
slavery was called a peculiar
institution or to get a gold medal
nobody's ever found when that reference
came up it just oddly enough
emerged in the very end of the the early
years of the 19th century when all of a
sudden one began talking about slavery
is a peculiar institution meaning of
course that he was confined almost
exclusively by that time to the southern
states and over and over again and
southerners didn't like to talk about
you know being slaveholders you didn't
you say you had servants if you were
properly brought up in the south you
didn't really want to talk about people
that you owned slaves so again you
didn't talk about a slave master you
talked about I live under the peculiar
institution this is kind of a euphemism
for saying that well it's not something
we want to talk about too much but we
live with it nevertheless but I wish you
could find that reference afar as if so
we'll gives you a gold medal yes
you talked about hypothetical
circumstances as to how certain
historical events may have come out had
Lincoln had close friends to confide in
but I'm wondering listening to talk and
most of my analogies come from reading
your biography of Lincoln it strikes me
that Lincoln had this tremendous ability
to be persistent in his own views and
all around him were either undermining
him or criticizing him and I'm wondering
if he needed to be somewhat of a loner
in order to be persistent had he had
close friends perhaps they would have
advised him away from some of the things
decisions that he stuck to that we now
admire I wonder if you could comment on
that this is a very interesting point I
think and again we're dealing with
hypotheticals so we don't truly know I
think a great faith in Mary Lincoln
statement about her husband and John Hay
sort of echoed this in a way Mary
Lincoln's statement was first of all
when her husband made up his mind on
something when he put his foot down flat
and you think of the agreed size
thirteen huge he put his foot down
nobody could budge him from me so
probably no advisor was going to budge
him on least fundamental all sorts of
things the John Hay statement though is
perhaps equally interesting John Hay
asked about Lincoln's mental
characteristics after the Civil War John
he was a very smart clever sometimes
superficial but a very bright observer
he said you know the problem that
Lincoln had in relating to other people
was that he was so superior to them he
had outgrown his earlier friends and he
knew that he was superior he didn't say
it he didn't have to say it but there
were people around him he said like
Charles Sunda like Solomon P Chase who
thought of themselves as being better
educated better qualified and so on and
they came upon this man who knew that he
was from odder than they were knew that
he had made the right decisions and who
certainly was not going to be influenced
by him so one does wonder Oh father
would have been possible today
major changes I don't think you could in
certain fact that matters as I've
suggested nobody could no advisor could
have advised Lincoln to say Oh after all
let those southern states go would be
good register get up stop rid of South
Carolina and of Mississippi in these
days I have idea Texas but oh you guys
have anybody at all so some matters he
was inflexible on but surely in the way
that he presented his ideas in the way
that he managed things there might have
been some adjustment so that if not a
different in outcome a difference in
public perception we have to remember
and he's often escapes us in Lincoln for
most of his administration was an
unpopular president they he was
considered incapable incompetent and
really not doing anything so that rather
than this presentation a close advisor
might have given some ammunition here
for saying we do have a policy we are
following through it's a reasonable
policy we defend for these reasons
he had nobody that he could help him
with that and he couldn't argue with
anybody else because there was nobody
around but again he wouldn't have
accepted a fundamental advice I'm sure
about that
sort of frame if you've lived longer
Elmer Ellsworth he was much younger
Elmer Ellsworth you see row square that
quickly just before the war he's a
leader of a drill team in Illinois he
originally was from New York Hey
and he was a great favorite of Lincoln
but of course he was killed almost war
was breaking out alexandrina came an
incident but Lincoln was apparently very
fond of him yes
this is again an interesting point that
one by making a larger kind of context
Lincoln always liked younger men he were
related to them much more easily and
they to him he was the mentor to many of
the young lawyers in Springfield
they studied with him are they read with
him or he advised him about legal cases
and Ellsworth was such a person Oh what
else worth would ever become a major
advisor
habited person no a leader of an army
this is all I think very doubtful he was
a very young man but Lincoln was deeply
fond of it and surely grieved when he
was killed so early whether he would be
considered an intimate friend or not I
rather doubt because the President of
the United States doesn't normally
confide
state policy and secrets to a 20 year
old but though there was a relationship
here which unfortunately was terminated
in some sense John Hay filled this role
in the later part of the the
administration and he realized that he
was a sounding board for Lincoln John
Hayes diary by the way is one of the
great wonderful documents of American
history I urge you all to read and enjoy
as you know or as you know we have where
we are about to have a Lincoln library
here there was a great deal of talk that
you would have been the ideal director
there's some talk that you may have been
invited and passed on it and I'd like to
ask you if that's true and if you had
been and you were not invited you had
been invited what would you have done it
that's another that's other
counterfactual
that is used to be that's rewriting
history notion have never been
approached by me about being director of
the evolve this new Lincoln Library
Museum which we are going to enjoy a
profit from nobody ever mentioned it and
I think nobody who knows we would ever
have thought of me in that connection
and the world's worst administrator
actually I have run a number of things
at Harvard primarily on the basis that I
don't dislike this I want to get it over
with let's finish it off quickly but how
did that's the mental attitude for the
drug shop here no this is not for me I'm
curious I think I think they have a very
good on you librarian coming in Richard
Owen Smith he's going to be a great
addition yeah do you think Lincoln
struggles with close personal
relationships informed his understanding
of the relationship between the north
and south and how did Lincoln imagine
his role in healing the spiritual rift
between northerners and southerners
following the war okay sorry
how did Lincoln imagine his his role and
healing the spiritual rift between
northerners and southerners following
the war yes certainly
Lincoln looked at the time that there
would be conciliation and that there
would be a renewed friendship among
southerners and others he felt this of
course in his own family where Mary
Todd's family had been so badly spit
with some serving in the Union Army
something in the Confederate armies I
mean killed in the Confederate Army for
that matter and this role of
conciliation is clear throughout
Lincoln's writings especially as he goes
on in years by the second inaugural
weather the whole emphasis here is on
let us get back together let us be
brothers together
let us be conciliatory now at the same
time though something's liquid was not
going to yielding that he was not for
example going to say oh well let's be
friends you keep the African Americans
in slavery or something of that sort no
no but in terms of personal
relationships of lack of bitterness that
he was remarkable and I think really
remarkable throughout American history
some tempting in time of conflict to
demonize your enemies and what evil
people they are and how wrong they are
and so on they couldn't really never did
this for instance he there's nothing to
go through all the Lincoln's papers and
not find anything attacking in Jefferson
Davis for example who certainly is
subject to attack I think on a variety
of scores but he did not personalize
ever it was always the idea that sooner
or later we've all got to live with each
other and live together as Americans so
I think this was the spirit he was going
in and this is what my third scenario of
counterfactual is I think really so
tragic if like that had lived or if
somebody else had been vice president
other than Andrew Johnson we might not
have had the bitter dish that arose
immediately after the war I think that
much of that could have been avoided and
of course he wasn't
please speculate as to what might have
happened when Lincoln faced shields in
the in the duel that was called I don't
know what everybody knows that story or
not but early on I think it was still in
the courtship just about there was
controversy about an Illinois official
named James Shields Irish born Democrat
or the pompous self-important but very
bright and clever and somebody published
in the local papers Simeon Francis his
name comes up here again in the local
papers a series of letters from Sian
Rebecca attacking and ridiculing James
Shields whose vanity was profile
anyway and whose feathers were easily
ruffled and he demanded that they also
be exposed so he'd call him to account
and ultimately Lincoln took the blame
for it though in fact he had may [ __ ]
he'd probably written how much of it but
all of this ultimately led to a
challenge toward a duel
the duel fortunately did not occur but
it was all scheduled and they were to go
on and I believe opposite Alton Illinois
Mississippi way it would be more or less
legal to fight a duel and try to kill
each other
Oh Lincoln shows us his weapons broad
swords which gave him in some ways a
great advantage because with his height
and his mix of arm and a road sword
sticking out there oh he could reach the
shields who's a little squat man who
couldn't and so it might not have worked
out well offer shields fortunately
fortunately it didn't come off our
mediators intervened but it was a source
of great embarrassment to Lincoln and
years later during the presidency
somebody indiscreetly referred to it in
his presence and he flushed and said and
I don't want to ever hear that mention
again that's not subject specularly for
American history by Deven and she was
killed Abraham Lincoln in 1840 on an
island in the Mississippi River but then
there's so many if but then of course
I've been playing with the Excel evening
haven't I
we are lincoln men is published by Simon
& Schuster on the web at Simon Says
dot-com next week on public lives the
grandchildren of Winston Churchill and
there are two books on the former Prime
Minister of England